directors Anthony and Joe Russo met with
Brolin and the digital effects artist
several months before live Shooting
began digital domains Kelly Port said it
was a proud moment to show off digital
domain's first Thanos test to Berlin and
the directors on the actor's first day
of shooting the results of digital
domain's first tests were encouraging
showing that the company's artists were
capable of maintaining Brolin's humanity
and Zayn case's performance in a virtual
skin according to dandeloo the early
test showed how much we could do with
the character it showed that wood could
take exactly what Brolin did on stage
and reproduce it with the CG character
the test put Brolin at ease letting the
actor know that he didn't need to
oversell his performance to make the
character feel alive as Kelly Port put
it I think what was really great about
his reaction was a sense that he did not
as an actor need to overplay the acting
seeing that the effects team would be
able to effectively translate a lower
key Thanos performance and all of its
subtleties was a boon to the filmmakers
especially Berlin who was worried about
how he would come off an emotion
captured performance